[Applause]
and we're gonna make a lovely Irish meal
is that correct we are I just want to
show you how to glaze the ham look we're
gonna glaze a ham I have it I have it
cooked for 1 hour
wrapped in parchment and foil parchment
foil see I put parchment in there so it
doesn't touch the foil that's just what
I would have done okay and then you
score it you can score it for me if you
want you know just go crisscross one way
and then the other you want to do that
okay that may be such a simple test so
just one way and then you're going to
slowly get drunk on this fabulous Irish
whiskey glaze this is actually delicious
so you add about 1/2 a cup of Irish
whiskey that's not about to about a cup
of brown sugar and get that all nice and
mixed up does the alcohol burn away in
the cooking or is it possible to get
drunk eating ham later no no you're not
gonna get drunk but it tastes so good it
really tastes good you're gonna have a
lot of other stuff dude okay you just
spoon this over put it back into like a
300 degree oven okay not all of it just
spoon the thick part the thick big part
so so this part this part over and then
bake a nice little crusty all over the
head and meat come together that's the
Irish soda bread which no meal should be
without on st. Patrick I have to say I
find it don't you find Irish soda bread
I'm gonna get so much mail for this did
a little dry you're like eating a dry
sponge I got up early this morning and I
made it for my editorial meeting I took
in it was nice and warm when I took it
in I don't know about Irish sort of look
at that very good part that's the Irish
answer to everything it's just butter
twit all of us they just eat this with a
spoon
sometime tomorrow taste look at that and
I'll make you a drink the butter is good
I know the bread is very good from my
baking book no that's very nice
and then it's nothing it's most
aesthetically pleasing bread though
somehow you don't I mean looks like a
brain or something we're missing we're
missing vodka or gin for the Irish Ricky
what are we making well Irish Irish
Ricky's but I don't see any any gin or
vodka
oh good sweat we can use that haha it
doesn't really matter to certain
because it does matter that's because if
it's gonna be Irish and Irish Ricky you
might as well use Irish whiskey yeah but
after three of them you don't care okay
try all right so just I put this in here
up to about half inch at the top okay
half inch at the top I mean a little
tiny bit any Ricky's are made with a
little bit of sparkling water just to
give them a little bit
[Applause]
don't tell me how to make and now would
you like a black and tan to wash that
down with your gonna make a black and
tan as well as the actress
that's Guinness Stout yes that is yes it
is Guinness Stout and you add bass and I
don't know why they have English and
Irish but but that's what they have we
can coexist amount they're doing very
nicely criss crossing in this glass mhm
and then you drink this oh I think that
looks absolutely
so do you drink these simultaneously
that looks better that looks better
oh that's gonna take that will still be
like this through Last Call with Carson
Daly that's gonna take a long time okay
try to go through the phone
doing just fine
and this is real by the way it's not
fake sometimes they fake these things
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
just hypnotize me with a shamrock that's
beautiful you cut the top of a little
deli container yes in the shape of a
shamrock
yes easy to do you can do that yes and
then brush a little royal icing oh
really
oh just like a stencil you know like
your children use stencils your miles
how many children do you have now I have
two children okay so your children I was
right okay and then you sprinkle
sprinkle green sugar you drive I like
drunk no no I'm not I'm just saying this
is cutting into valuable drinking time
I like the cookie as much as anyone else
and there you have a shamrock cookie
thank you what beautiful look at that
everybody about cookie and these
stencils are easy to make
[Applause]
yeah I like the darkens hand is very
good yeah the black anti-migrant can do
Ricky I mean it's good it's fine but no
look at the old painting day so this is
colcannon which is like a irish take on
the bubble and squeak I don't know what
you just said that's that's what it's
like when you're new UK it's like have
some kibble at Babel here try but a half
a Dibley do try all of that what is this
it's put mashed potato mm-hmm with
cabbage and leek oh isn't it good yeah
but it's still not alcohol
[Applause]
beautiful ham is just looking over the
place of that ham I would just hang that
on a rope from my apartment when I get
on the morning tonight
oh that's gonna be good right here's
gonna be so good oh my god is so good
yeah like the glaze what's that Irish
whiskey glaze yes yes a brown sugar yes
yes I can you worked alcohol onto the
ham as well I do is that a good ham it's
a beautiful hand this has been fantastic
I would like to stick my face into all
this food about 40 minutes and never be
saving it for you for the Ender and your
band the band needs it thank you Martha
thank you for being here the Martha
Stewart Show airs weekdays check your
local listings and the Kirkland
Signature Martha Stewart favorite
holiday ham is available exclusively at
Costco it's where I shop don't you
[Applause]